Thanos has had some ridiculously op
moments in Marvel Comics check this out
so at one point Thanos got the Cosmic
Cube which was literally a wishing box
that allowed him to do whatever he
wanted to and he became one with the
universe following that he got The
Infinity Gauntlet which as most of you
guys know he used it to dust half the
life in the universe and then became one
with the universe again and the
far-flung future in a story called
Thanos wins Thanos kills every Cosmic
entity Across the Universe and then sees
his control of all reality and then
becomes one with the universe and then
Thanos attained the god Quarry which is
some enigmatic source of power that lets
people do incredible things we don't
really know exactly what he did with it
presumably he became one with the
universe there was also a one-in story
called Marvel the end where Thanos
attained something called The Heart of
the universe and then became one with
the Multiverse and then in more recent
years Thanos got something called the
astral regulator which he used to kill
God and then became one with the
Multiverse again make sure you guys
follow for more